it is being reported that Russian
President Vladimir Putin is readying
nuclear weapons what does this mean can
we trust it but maybe most importantly
what is it actually like to theorize
about what would happen if such weapons
were to be Unleashed so let's start with
the beginning a number of not very good
sources and then some okay sources are
reporting things like what Newsweek is
reporting Russia primes nuclear bomb 12
times more powerful than that dropped on
Hiroshima now let's break down the
headline more powerful than that dropped
on Hiroshima this is a very common 21st
century headline the it's very common
that now the nukes that countries have
access to are more powerful than the one
that was dropped on Hiroshima so that
doesn't tell us too too much but let's
look into the details video of an
intercontinental ballistic missile on a
silo launcher has been released by
Russia's defense Ministry and widely
reported by the country's media in an
apparent warning to the West a Russian
tabloid newspaper reported that the yars
missile complex which was loaded in the
Kaluga region had a capacity 12 times
greater than the American bomb that
destroyed Hiroshima in 1945. the mass
circulation papers report outlined some
of the missiles specifications including
a launch weight of 46 000 tons which
some are disputing as plausible as
implausible an operational range of up
to 12 000 kilometers that can strike the
U.S or anywhere in Europe and a payload
of up to 500 kilo tons now is Putin
doing this and what might cause him to
do something like this we can't say with
complete and total certainty so I think
it's maybe more interesting and more
relevant to talk generally about what
this would be like what would it look
like geopolitically and in term terms of
the science of it if Russia launched a
nuke of roughly this size against the
West often we just say well it would be
a general nuclear winter nuclear
Holocaust but I find that it's better to
be a little more specific the exact
outcomes of what would happen if Russia
were to launch one of these nukes let's
let's put it at one for the time being
as more likely that it would be one
rather than a bunch just for the sake of
discussion uh the consequences would
really depend on the specific Target uh
and and the number of weapons used but
the potential consequences would likely
include the destruction of whatever city
is hit and the infrastructure of that
City so you're talking buildings you're
talking roads Bridges and power grids
already catastrophic but those are the
primary impacts then we have to talk
about the sort of like follow-on effects
you then would have contamination of
large areas with radiation
that has significant consequences in
terms of long-term health effects for
the survivors uh potentially making the
areas uninhabitable and of course the
impact that that would have on the
ability to grow food remember the
bridges are destroyed the roads are
destroyed so if you can't grow food
where do you bring food from if the
bridges and the and and the roads are
also destroyed so you can see how these
are compounding effects economic
disruption on a global scale trade and
financial markets would likely be
devastated a significant geopolitical
escalation would likely likely happen
it's sort of an understatement I think
the question is to what extent and how
quickly does the West respond in kind
does this lead to a full-scale war
involving nuclear weapons which these
are these are just such dystopian
scenarios that it can be hard to think
about them uh sort of in Practical terms
and then of course the general increase
in likelihood that other countries would
use their own nuclear weapons and and a
global nuclear conflict that could
develop really important to understand
the catastrophic nature here I mean
think about just one item like to go
back to food supply
nuclear bombing would have a
catastrophic effect on the food supply
in the affected areas the explosion
itself would destroy Farmland crops
livestock food stores that exist so you
immediately have food shortages the
contamination of the environment with
radiation could make it difficult or
even impossible to grow crops to raise
animals in those affected areas
furthering the food shortages into long
term then you've got to bring food in
from somewhere else but the
infrastructure was destroyed as I
mentioned the roads the bridges the
ports so transporting food in becomes
difficult exacerbating those very
shortages and and so just to take one
area of food the use of a nuke could
devastate the food supply and leave lead
to widespread starvation so that's just
food that we're talking about how long
would areas be affected by a nuke the
effects of radiation on the environment
can last for years
and it can take a significant amount of
time before it would be safe to live in
an affected area
to to grow food in an effective area to
affected area to raise animals it can
take a very long time and in some cases
effects can be what for the human
lifespan we would call permanent or
semi-permanent so
we don't know what's going on with Putin
right now health questions questions
about his mental state questions about
what is the game plan here with what's
going on in Ukraine and we have
increasing but isolated and not
exquisitely well sourced reports that
nukes are being readied we have to hope
of course it doesn't go in that
direction and to the extent that
diplomacy can be used to prevent that we
should welcome it